[Music]
is the most wonderful time of the year
it is award season and every year as the
Oscars come around distinctive assets
sends these goodie bags to all the
nominees in the top category that
includes a Best Actor Best Actress Best
Supporting Actor Best Supporting Actress
and Best Director recipients this year
include Lady Gaga Rami Malek Bradley
Cooper Emma Stone Amy Adams to name a
few so they have the option to claim
anything that's in this bag one thing
that's in this bag or we don't have to
claim anything in the bag these bags are
worth over $100,000 so let's see what
some of the stars are getting this year
oh gosh I love this down
[Applause]
[Music]
wait do you even have to what this or is
this kind of like oh wow I feel like
Hannibal Lecter Oh beautiful yeah I
really wonder if this is all the mask
works this is kind of like pulling on my
face I feel like it has like tightening
benefits like Botox do I it reduces
wrinkles improve skin texture tightens
the skin I knew it this is really
pulling on my skin Oh perfect okay so
this box I feel like it's like a diamond
or something a lot of diamond California
Summerland what is it it's like an
absolute smoke with friends oh okay so
this is like like a bong type thing it's
a pipe I wouldn't know but yeah they hug
this - chocolate chocolate teens oh this
is last year's bag these were so good
they're back again
to delight in the sweet tooths of all
the stars it was like exactly what you
want whether you win or lose an Oscar
it's not some chocolate this is a
cannabis bath soap treatment Oh
interesting
Wow they have a lot of cannabis products
here you know what mister brought
scissors here Wow I am sweating every
time I do these Oscar gift bag stuff I
sweat me because I can't afford these
stuff this is probably like a year
supply of like tooth stuff like fancy
tooth stuff it's actually very handy
when you go to award shows if they get
all the time I feel like you would want
this like you know when you're accepting
an award you don't want to be like with
your bad breath let's try out see how
this is I've never done breath spray oh
well I like it though I actually like
this I would claim this breath spray
more chocolates
normally these chocolates are infused
with cannabis but they're not infused
today because I'm trying them in the
office so it literally says it on the
package not infused sample okay so don't
come at me say this is from MZ skin
oh cool fun fact this has real gold in
it you can see my hand shimmering with
richness so along with the gold serum
they have an eye mask which is kind of
cool ah so soothing the dark circles are
vanishing right away okay for um Zuzu
Kim what is this oh it's a bowtie this
is adorable
I feel lady gaga's definitely gonna
claim this the pricier stuff in the bags
are like all these vacations and trips
you can take you can either go to the
Amazon voyage that Galapagos voyage
Iceland voyage or Costa Rica Panama
voyage so you have four trips you can
choose from and you can take one of
those and just get away from the
paparazzi this is incredible this is so
fun like who doesn't want free stuff
like I'm sure the oscars are a really
stressful time for whoever's nominated
and if you don't win at least you have a
bunch of other gifts you can go home to
here's a lot of like beauty and cannabis
products chocolates so you're not losing
your winning everyone wins
[Music]
it's a party it's the Oscars it's an
Oscars party everyone's joining
[Music]